- So here you are with your first check
for doing a comedy show.
Look at your little face.
- Oh!
(audience applause)
- Your little face with
your braces! I love you.
- Oh my God. Yeah.
- It's $435.79. So what show was that for?
- It was for my first
television show appearance
on Comedy Central's show
called "Make Me Laugh".
And I did the show and
when I got the check,
I'm like it took me two
minutes to make this.
And then in my head, I did the ghetto math
where I'm
- Ghetto math!
- Ghetto math, where I'm like,
if I did this for eight hours, how much,
you know, you just start
having those fantasies.
- Yes.
(audience applause)
- Do you remember the
first thing you bought
with your first professional money?
Do you remember?
- That right there.
Yes. And I still have it. A leather jacket
from Wilson's House of Suede.
- I bought a coat. I bought
a coat. I remember that.
- Yeah. It had the liner
with the zipper. Right.
And then it had the thing.
- Oh yes!
- Oh, it was bad. I still got it.
- [Drew] Fancy.
- Still fits too, what!
- [Drew] Fancy! I was like,
(audience laughter)
I was like, literally
remembering and I was like,
well, that's yester year.
Can't fit into that.
So do you remember your
first acting paid gig though?
- I was an understudy for a play called
"Six Degrees of Separation" outta school,
which was a Broadway show. It was amazing.
I was the happiest understudy ever,
like most under studies
were sort of like, yeah,
I'm never going on, but I loved it.
I was, I would sit in the catwalk.
I would sit way up high
and watch the show.
I loved it to pieces. Yeah.
- I love that. I love those moments too.
Like where I hope I never,
I don't feel like I,
I still get excited. I hope
I never get jaded like that.
You know, you run into
people that get jaded.
- Oh, it's only.
- Yeah.
- And I don't know where
the accent came from
but that's how I sound when
I look at mine.
- You go.
I love that she becomes an old smoker
and you become an old British man.
- I say, they tried to pay me in Pesos.
(Kelly laughs)
- British. Pesos.